thank you
new tonight a teacher's Union poll shows
71 percent of members want
superintendent Dr Jara fired with around
600 people participating in that survey
of those voters 51 percent had an
unfavorable opinion of Dr Jara compared
to just 14 percent who had a favorable
one now the school district responded to
the poll from Clark County Education
Association saying this
quote ccea continued its targeted
research and polls in a bad faith effort
to influence contract negotiations given
the dubious nature of previous survey
results promoted by the teachers union
in Southern Nevada the district
questions the validity of any polls not
shared publicly